i'm
kimberly harvey i'm a dance artist
choreographer
teacher and so i have my own company
subtle craft car
and then i'm a freelance artist and i
also
work for kanduko dance company as a
kentico artist
[Music]
for all of the work that i do whether
that be
choreographer as a teacher one of the
key themes for me is always relationship
whether that be to a space or to other
people or to
myself so that's what runs through
everything and then on top of that
over the past maybe a couple of years
i've been
gathering research around themes of
holding
and both on my own and also with other
artists
um and so this idea of holding spaces in
different ways
and i'm drawn to spaces that hold
me so i will often
choose to put myself in
corners or like behind pillars or in
alcoves
where i kind of um
yeah there's a sense of being held by
the space
i sort of have two works that really
stand out for me one is um a solo that i
made most recently
um called inky mata
and it's basically i'm fascinated by
letters and particularly handwritten
ones
and for ages i thought that it was only
me
um and and and then i sort of realized
that i had lots of
letters in me that i'd never written or
that i had never sent
and then the more i talk to people the
more i realized that
they did as well um
and i also found that for me i
placed the letters in very particular
parts of my body
so that was a as a doctor and maker that
was a
perfect starting point
[Laughter]
and then the other one is a film i made
a few years ago now
and which is called on the tip of my
tongue
which i made with a
friend and colleague of mine and the
reason i love it
is because it came from me
going to andrew graham who's
um the other performer and saying
we've known each other for four years
but i've never actually
directed with you i love what you do as
a dancer and as a
as an artist i want to work with you and
i want to make a dance film
and and he said and i said to him would
you be up for it and he said yes
um and from there we then
sort of created the brief of the film
together
and it was what is our language as a
duet
and because he's almost six foot
and i'm definitely not six foot
um and i'm yes i'm out of the chair for
part of it as well
and so we did some in the chair and some
out of the chair and
because of the relationship that we have
it's also one of trust so i was able
to do things with him in a very short
space of time
[Music]
i love that my job
enables me to play
and to communicate in a variety of ways
as a teacher as a choreographer and as a
performer
and i think as adults particularly we
leave
the ability to play we get told that
we're too old to play or that
you know we should be serious now
because we're adults the the dancing
in a dance environment you see a micro
world which is
really beautiful and things happen in in
a making in a
creative setting that you kind of wish
you could
diffuse to everybody because we're not
frightened of proximity we're
less fearful of touch and we're less
fearful of communicating in a variety of
diverse ways there's an openness in a
creative space which there isn't
to the wider world
[Applause]
you